thrills spills chills and kills this is
why we go to the movies to see big
amazing and probable and/or impossible
stuff happen on the big screen it gets
the blood pumping to see impressive
feats of stunt work and death defiance
which is why tons of action movies come
out every year while many are certainly
satisfying only a few contain that
elusive combination of a great story
unforgettable characters and the
unmatched technical mastery necessary to
transcend John Rowe thrills and achieve
great cinema here are lubbers fixed for
the best action movies ever made die
hard part of the reason 1988 die hard
worked so well is its cinematic context
action movies at the time all tended to
features stoic dudes with huge muscles
laying waste with folder size fists and
machine guns never doubting their utter
alpha-male Ness and barely cracking a
smile
contrast that with die hard in which
Bruce Willis is a relatively normal
sized normal-looking guy who cracks wise
and expresses fear and self-doubt as he
almost single-handedly beats back
terrorists to literally save Christmas
diehard also gave us a breakout
performance from the beloved Alan
Rickman as Hans Gruber one of the
all-time great movie villains efficient
about cooperative not a lot to ask
allows you or mr. Takagi did not see it
that way so he won't be joining us for
the rest of his life the Dark Knight
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
is really more like one long movie but
the middle part is definitely the best
chapter showing the result of Bruce
Wayne's training in Batman Begins and
the start of what will play out in the
Dark Knight Rises 2008's The Dark Knight
is arguably the best made superhero
movie of all time with a tone that
reflects the character and shows utter
faithfulness to the comics it's based on
what would I do at how you go back to
ripping out my dealers no no no no you
you complete me the French Connection
gene Hackman's tough-guy cop Jimmy
Popeye Doyle just never stops running
for driving or roughing up criminals in
the pursuit of justice even if he has to
Don a Santa suit while doing so I went
along I got a stream gripe about his
bowling scores
now I'm going to bust your ass for those
three bags I'm gonna nail you from
picking your fingers
despite being self Renetta so tough so
new and so very violent 1971 the French
Connection won best picture at the
Academy Awards the first r-rated flick
ever to do so the Bourne Identity in
2002 as the James Bond franchise was
slumping its way through an era of stale
lazily delivered cliches the Bourne
Identity hit theaters a refreshingly
modern wholly American spy movie that
reflected a more modern environment of
geopolitics Matt Damon's ultra trained
super warrior doesn't know who he is but
he's definitely aware of his own
incredible fighting abilities thanks to
the paranoid cheeky camerawork and
urgent pace the audience rarely knows
more than Jason Bourne does and as a
result they never quite gets thick
breath even Raiders of the Lost Ark it's
supposed to be an homage to the
action-adventure serials that director
Steven Spielberg and producer George
Lucas grew up watching in the 1950s but
the thing is those often weren't very
good movies 1981's Raiders of the Lost
Ark however completely overshadows its
source material and is merely a perfect
film every scene is crowd-pleasing
particularly the iconic action sequences
Raiders is pure fun beginning to end
Robocop 1987 Robocop is a violent
action-packed futuristic cop movie or is
it a violent action-packed futuristic
cop movie that satirizes violent
action-packed movies from the eighties
you have the right to remain silent you
[Music]
like any good work of satire it works on
both levels
Robocop has a lot to say about the value
of human life in the crime-ridden future
world of new Detroit after all it's
about a cop struck down by some pretty
intense violence and then resurrected as
a cyborg designed to execute as many
criminals as humanly possible the matrix
a college-level philosophy class was
never so eye-popping 1999's the matrix
kind of blew everybody's minds with its
central conceit that there's no point to
human life beyond their bodies being
bags of energy neo gets to decide if
he's cool with that or if he wants to
try to exist on a higher plane with his
own free will pretty heavy stuff for the
multiplex but the matrix features a lot
of bells and whistles such as the insane
fight between neo and Agent Smith and
that innovative bullet time effect which
seemed to bend time itself speed by the
mid-90s action movies were dying under
their own ways huge budgets meant lots
of explosions but not a lot of depth or
character then came 1994 is speed an all
killer no filler thrill ride couched in
a simple premise if a Los Angeles City
bus blows - under 50 miles per hour a
bomb planted on board explodes it breaks
with form to make for lots of surprises
and the plot necessitates absolutely
non-stop action just got a ransom demand
from your dead terrorists says he's read
the city bus where's Jack where do you
think I got a good on that bus
yeah yeah you get on the bus but there's
also a lot of humanity to speed every
day people from many different walks of
life are thrust together onto the city
bus and they come together as a team to
rise up and meet the challenge
Terminator 2 Judgment Day the original
Terminator from 1984 is pretty fantastic
in zone right dark gritty weird and
menacing all with a charming low budget
hair the 1992 follow-up Terminator 2 was
one of the most expensive movies of all
time but the money is all up there on
the screen especially well executed is
the iconic motorcycles vs. semi-truck
chase scene and every time a puddle of
liquid metal reshaped itself into that
evil Terminator still cool and still
looking state of the art after more than
25 years Bullitt Steve McQueen was one
of the first action stars and a pioneer
the form he even did as many of his own
stunts as the film studios would let him
for example he did some of the driving
for the landmark on location car chase
team in 1968 Bullitt the plot is loaded
with twists and intrigue and it all
culminates as lieutenant Frank Bullitt
chases the bad guys in their 1968 Dodge
Charger through the very real very hilly
streets of San Francisco
no standard-issue police cruiser for
bullets he's got a sweet 1968 Ford
Mustang GT the high-speed pursuit ends
in the best possible way
Mad Max fury road reboots generally
don't work and even if they do they're
still doomed to pale in comparison to
the original thing not so with Mad Max
fury road which expands and improves on
the Mad Max universe with a nonstop ride
through the familiar harrowing
post-apocalyptic wasteland on modified
cars piloted by crazy survival driven
nomadic warriors Mad Max creator George
Miller returned to direct fury road and
it's 35 plus years of experience as a
filmmaker are up there on the screen
with an action movie that's both
endlessly thrilling and emotionally
compelling plus there's a character
called doof warrior who plays a fire
spewing electric guitar if you're still
like event gladiator swords and sandals
movies hadn't been popular for decades
when director Ridley Scott and star
Russell Crowe brought them back in a big
way with 2000's gladiator the film won
the Academy Award for Best Picture and
Crowe won Best Actor for his
performances Roman general turn slaves
Maximus father to emoted son husband to
emoted wife and I will have my vengeance
against a classical Roman backdrop
audiences referred Maximus his quest to
avenge the misdeeds of the evil emperor
win its freedom and survive the brutal
arena and Scott stages some of the most
thrilling action sequences ever put the
film Jurassic Park the original Jurassic
Park was a revelation in 1993
popularizing a sub-genre known as the
techno thriller pioneered by author
Michael Crichton these fables inevitably
involve technology run amuck to the
shock and horror of the humans that
created it before you even knew you had
you you've patented it and packaged it
and slapped it on a plastic lunchbox and
now you're selling but of course that's
all a lot of fun to watch especially
when the technology is realistic
dinosaurs hunting humans under a
majestic unforgettable score by John
Williams all brought to life with
masterful direction by Steven Spielberg
add it all up and you've got a modern
masterpiece of popcorn cinema lethal
weapon detectives Riggs and Murtaugh
Gore mismatched cops
one's a loose cannon who doesn't play by
the rules and the other is a by-the-book
guy who is
1987 lethal weapon makes this formula
work because the chemistry between Mel
Gibson and Danny Glover is so charming
that and the plot largely couched in
dark comedy never goes where the
audience thinks it well you want to be
crazy oh that's a real bad double real
confidence a real gun even 30 years
later this never gets old the Avengers
the superhero genre really got going
when Marvel Studios started laying the
groundwork for its vast cinematic
universe driving the stage for arguably
the single greatest superhero team-up
possible for the Avengers long awaited
big screen debut Marvel hired a director
who nearly understood comic books Joss
Whedon and assembled a cast of acclaimed
actors who really understood how to
deliver Whedon's witty dialogue alright
hey alright good job guys
let's just not come in tomorrow I said
take it no expense was spared making a
movie that was limitless in terms of
superpowers earth-shattering sight
things from faith like a comic book come
to life the Avengers is now the standard
by which all other big fun superhero
movies are judged Kill Bill Quintin
Tarantino's Kill Bill is an epic tale of
revenge centered on a hero of near
superhuman abilities and unrelenting
focus but with enough vulnerabilities in
human motivation to make audiences
report uma thurman's bride goes on a
quest to locate and murder every member
of the squad that left her for dead
years earlier and find the baby she was
pregnant with at the time of the attack
the trail ultimately leads to the gangs
leader and her baby father David
Carradine till but along the way the
bride must subdue each of her enemies an
insanely choreographed fight sequence
any number of which would be the
centerpiece of any semi-decent action
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]